First of all, we were talking about creativity. Uh, how,
how is that? How is creativity and sleep connected?
They are very connected. Uh, we know that sleep inspires problem solving.
It's sort of, it's almost as though sleep is like, um,
it's a group therapy for memories that sleep gathers in all of the information
that you've been learning during the day.
And it starts to collide it in these strange, connected ways.
It's sort of informational alchemy as it were so that you wake up the next
day with a revised mind wide web of associations.
And we can now demonstrate that in the laboratory,
we can sort of give you these problems to solve that seem difficult before
sleep. And then we give you a full eight hours.
We measure your sleeping brainwaves.
You wake up the next day and you're three times more likely to be able to solve
a problem than if you just to stay awake on a problem.
And that's the reason that no one has ever told you to stay awake on a problem.
Instead, they tell you to sleep on it on a problem. And, and what,
what I find fascinating about that in every language that I've inquired about to
date that phrase, sleeping on a problem, it seems to exist, you know,
from French to Swahili. Um, you know, we, the British,
we say you sleep on a problem.
I think the French translation is a little bit closer to you sleep with a
problem.
Yeah. You know,
[inaudible] says so much about the difference between the British and the French
British. We speak French, we sleep with a prop.
So be it, this is the, this is the good side of sleep.
But also, I mean, we do sleep less. I mean, we,
a hundred years ago we slept a lot more didn't we?
That's right. Yeah. So a survey done back in 1942,
demonstrated that the average adult was sleeping 7.9 hours a night.
Now that number is closer to six hours and 30 minutes.
So there's been this incredible erosion of sleep time throughout industrialized
nations. It's happened across probably about the past 70 years.
That's almost 20%. You know, it took mother nature,
3.6 million years to put this necessity of eight hours of sleep in
place. And then within the space of an evolutionary blink of the eye,
we've locked off 20% of that time.
Many people try, they try to sleep,
but either they can't fall asleep or they will, they will wake up midnight.
And I mean at four in the morning and
be able to sleep again.
Yeah. And those are classically the two forms of insomnia that we have.
One is called sleep onset, insomnia, difficulty falling asleep,
the other's called sleep maintenance insomnia. So you can fall asleep,
but you can't stay asleep. You wake back up.
And certainly what we know is that one of the principal causes of insomnia,
which by the way, is twice as likely to be present in women than in men.
It's a far more female, um, impacted disorder. Um,
the principal,
cause there seems to be anxiety that that sort of fight or flight branch of the
nervous system gets ramped up. And when that gets ramped up,
it's very difficult to fall asleep. So what do you do about that? Well,
there's lots of things you can try.
Meditation has been demonstrated to be remarkably effective.
It just sort of quiet down the nervous system allows you to fall asleep. Um,
the other thing is actually a worry journal now as a hard-nosed
scientist, when I was looking at the evidence and reviewing this, um,
I thought it surely doesn't work, which is an hour before bed.
Just write down all of the concerns and the things that you have on your mind.
It helps you. Do.
You do that with practice? If I get journaling?
Yeah. I just do write down all my IDs and everything I worry about.
And also in the sad times,
everything I have to be happy about and it really helps me fall asleep.
It's really good. I do it.
Finish it with at least three things that are positive three good things about
your day or three things that you're grateful for. You already know it,
which is great.
But, but it's, it's uh,
another alternative of course is a simpler is sleeping pills.
Would be true. Unfortunately though,
there are three problems with sleeping pills. Firstly,
they are a class of drugs that we call the sedative hypnotics and sedation is
not sleep, but you mistake the former for the latter. When you take these pills,
now they just not your cortex out.
The other two issues is that sleeping pills have been associated with a
significantly higher risk of death, as well as cancer,
which is where you work with a therapist.
And it's a psychological intervention just as effective as sleeping pills in the
short term. But what's great is that when you finish with your therapist,
you keep that good sleep going. Whereas when you stop taking sleeping pills,
you usually not only go back to the bad sleep that you are having,
you often have, what's called rebound insomnia,
which is that your sleep gets even worse. You're a fan of separate bedrooms.
Yeah.
So I think for some people with sleep divorce can prevent you from having a real
one. Um,
we know that about 30 to 40% of people who are surveyed anonymously,
by the way,
will admit to not sleeping in the same bed of the remaining people who do go to
bed and sleep or start trying to sleep in the same bed.
They often wake up in a different bed.
About 50% of those will wake up in a different bed. And what's,
I think interesting is that partners will often disrupt sleep males far
more likely to snore and have a sleep disorder that we call sleep apnea.
As I said, females twice,
the rates of insomnia and that tossing and turning and that snoring can cause
it can cause poor sleep in one or both of the partners.
And when you have a sleep divorce,
essentially you start sleeping in separate bedrooms or you sleep in separate
beds. Now the stigma there is that if you're not sleeping together,
then you're not sleeping together. But the opposite is true.
What we know is that men who are not sleeping well will have a level of
testosterone, which is that of someone 10 years, their senior.
So a lack of sleep will age a man by a decade. And for a woman,
we also know that for every extra hour of sleep that she adds,
there is a 13 to 15% increase in the desire to be physically intimate with
her partner.
If you're getting good sleep, I'm going to get some sleep,
is the message coming across it. So.
Oddly enough, ironically, if you're,
if you're sleeping well in separate bedrooms,
your physical relationship tends to actually improve as a company.
Interested in the idea of a sleep divorce because my husband snores a lot.
He has sleep apnea, but I'm very aware that if we slept in different bedrooms,
he would die because it's when you have sleep apnea. This is why.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yes.
I have to save his life. I have to wake up and then I saved his life.
So if I was sleeping in another room, I would get a lot more sleep myself,
but my husband would be dead. Like kind of, can you die of sleep?
Apnea is basically what I'm asking you. Can you die of snoring.
And die of snoring,
but you die chronically because the disrupted sleep will lead to an increase
risk of things like diabetes, stroke or cardiovascular.
Disease. To be honest.
I'm not going to rush to judgment on that.
But clearly the sleep issue is causing you some,
some anger problems that we can, we can talk about, but in all seriousness,
that that sort of chopping and the cessation of breath.
It happens, you know, five to 10 times an hour.
Or a minute. In fact, now.
If you were to say to someone, you know,
I'm going to come into your room every night and maybe about 40 or 50 times
throughout tonight,
I'm going to strangle you to the point where you stop breathing. It's not there.
Yeah. That's ridiculous that that's terrible. Yeah.
No one would do that to me,
but that's what the disorder of sleep apnea will do to someone it's a
horrifically serious disorder. So if you know someone who's snoring,
please go and have them see a doctor. Um, it is life-threatening,
it will bring on and hasten the speed of many of those diseases that are killing
us. I can just show him.
Exactly. This is perfect,
where you can bring him home and he can tell you directly to your husband
[inaudible] is it a big difference between the quality or what,
what is most important? The quality or the quantity of sleep?
We used to.
Think it was quantity. And the advice we give is, you know,
somewhere around eight hours of sleep. And, and you asked me the question,
you know, I certainly give myself a non-negotiable eight hour sleep opportunity.
Um, not because I want to be a poster child or sort of, you know,
practice what I preach. If you understood the importance of sleep as I do,
you it's selfish,
you would choose to do nothing other than give yourself that sleep. You know,
I don't want, um, disease or sickness. I don't want to short a life.
I want a longer life and a longer, healthier life,
but it's the best insurance policy that I know of in terms of healthcare.
So certainly quantity is important, but probably in the last five or six years,
quality is also critical too. It's a combination of the two.
So just because you may be in bed for eight hours,
if you're not getting that continuous sleep and the deep quality sleep first,
and then the sort of the dream sleep later in the night,
you need all of these things to get those benefits. I am in trouble.
Me too.
Yeah. I'm a desperately depressing guest on
[inaudible]. You'll see a lot of politicians bragging about,
I only need four hours of sleep.
I only need five hours of legendary politicians.
Like, like, uh, Margaret Thatcher.
Ronald Reagan, uh.
Current head of state in America, you know, Donald Trump.
They don't sleep much count
[inaudible] do they? I mean, does it help with power naps then? Do you,
I mean, is that where power comes from? Well, firstly, we know that.
The number of people who can survive on seven hours of sleep or less without
showing any impairment rounded to a whole number and expressed as a percent of
the population is zero. I see.
So once to anyone suggesting that they can survive on five or four hours of
sleep, um, is a fallacy. And you know, it strikes me as interesting.
One of the most significant lifestyle factors determining whether or not you
will develop Alzheimer's disease is the amount of sleep that you're getting.
Because at night there is this remarkable cleansing system that kicks into high
gear that washes away the toxic proteins that are linked to Alzheimer's disease.
So you get this power cleanse at night, it's sort of good, night's sleep clean.
You know, technology is a problem. Uh, the image, uh, sort of issue I think is,
is problematic caffeine, alcohol. Those two are not the friends of sleep.
It turns out only, only.
Caffeine in the morning or yeah.
Yeah. So caffeine in the morning is okay, you know,
a couple Oh two in the morning,
but one of the problems with caffeine is that it has a half-life of six
hours and it has a quarter-life of 12 hours.
What that means is that if you have a cup of coffee at noon,
a quarter of that caffeine is still circulating in your brain at midnight.
So if you have a cup of coffee, you know, around midday,
it's the equivalent of getting into bed at night.
And before you turn the light out,
you Swick a quarter of a cup of coffee and you hope for a good night of sleep.
It's just not going to happen.
Alcohol is that also in the morning?
It's strange, but, uh, alcohol.
Is again a group of drugs that we call the sedative. So again,
you're just knocking yourself out with the nightcap alcohol also litters your
sleep with many more awakenings, it's called fragmented sleep.
So you don't feel as restored by your sleep the next morning and find the
alcohol is a very powerful drug of blocking your dream sleep.
And so the advice that I would never give on a television program in
front of a public audience would be, yes,
you should go to the pub in the morning.
Um, that way by the evening, the alcohol is out consistent.
And you're just fine, but I would never say that as, as a professional,
you know.
Could we cut that?
[inaudible] I have to ask you because we're one week away here in Europe now,
uh, w from what we call summertime or,
or I think it's called daylight savings time. That's right. Yeah. Um,
uh, and, and then we, we changed sort of changed the day. I,
you have it in America as well. I think you have it already. That's right. Yeah.
And so, um, does that affect us?
It affects us markedly, and I think there's good reason to,
to disabuse society of that impact. And you may think, you know,
what's the harm of one hour of sleep. Well, I'll tell you this in the spring,
when we lose one hour of sleep,
the next day we see a subsequent 24% increase in heart attacks,
which is dramatic.
And we see an equivalent rise in the risk of suicide,
suicidal thoughts, suicidal attempts, suicide completion.
We also see a spike in road traffic accidents that following day,
this is all just one hour of lost sleep.
This is how fragile and vulnerable our bodies are to even just the smallest
perturbation of sleep. Now in the autumn, in the fall,
when we gain an hour of sleep,
we see a beautiful 21% reduction in heart attacks.
So it's bi-directional why are we doing this to society?
May we should maintain stability so we should take it away.
I think we should take it away. Take it away.
Yeah. Thank you.
It's actually something that is quite easy to do, do, do something.
Yeah. It's really not that difficult.
And the lives that it could save would be non-trivial.
Yeah, y'all gonna, y'all gotta do a song called animal. Uh,
so please take the stage. Thank you so much.
[inaudible] they know how to sleep well,
human beings are the only species that deliberately deprived itself of sleep for
no apparent reason.
No other species throughout evolution has decided to take sleep away.
Matthew, thank you so much for being
[inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.